anyway you please Tom was hair looks
sexy pushed back Regina was dangling
Aaron in front of me on purpose I knew
how this would be settled in the animal
world I can't do it I got it that's
going up oh I can't watch what you're
less water that's horrible
no I can't put it in your butt
Angie cats can do this come on in there
just try just relax
close your eyes do it swallow it take it
there you go
you did it
did you just and just like that
Charlotte who kept sleeping in her pants
do you recall the doctor no this day
Christmas New Year's fourth of July
she's fine
Valentine's Day not so good what are you
doing tonight Calvin
and they want me to start straightaway
um so I've got to leave about Oh three
minutes so um what would you just hold
it right there I'm sorry to inform you
but I think you'll find it by contract
you're expected to give at least six
weeks notice
ah yes well you know I thought what's
the company being in so much trouble and
all you wouldn't really miss the person
who waltzes in and a see-through top and
Fanny's about with the press releases
don't you think you're a little old to
be using cheesy pickup lines objection
leading the witness
Wow hand are you really wearing that
dress that you're doing that a favor
yeah that's the line me sitting over
there for the past two hours not being
able to take my eyes off of you is a
fact I mean there's lots of beautiful
women in this bar your friend included
hi I love you
I used Photoshop at work today to
composite our faces together to see what
our kids would look like our family
album
you don't want to see her children we
don't have
children
hey buddy you to him good I felt I'm so
much more relaxed thank you hello I just
feel like I'm excited and I feel relaxed
and I'm ready to my best man I'm gonna
go down to the river
Wow it looks like somebody's really
relaxing this gym membership hey you
want me to lose weight watch it it's
late no we can't legally ask you to do
that we didn't say lose weight I might
say tightened tight tighter just like
toned and smaller don't make everything
smaller I don't want to generalize that
way tighter we don't want you to lose
weight we just want you to be healthy
okay no bye-bye eating less we would
just like it if you go home and step on
a scale and write down how much you
weigh and subtract it by like 20 and
then weigh that much